♪ ♪
OOP, UH, PARDON ME.
- HEY, PLAYER.
- HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
- HEY, CAN I MAKE
A REQUEST?
- FOR SURE, MAN.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR?
- HEY, MAN, HOOK A BROTHER
UP WITH SOME OLD SCHOOL.
- OH, YEAH,
ALL RIGHT, WORD.
OKAY, WHAT YOU LOOKING FOR--
BIGGIE, TUPAC?
- BIGGIE, TUPAC?
COME ON, MAN,
THAT'S TOO NEW.
I'M TALKING
ABOUT THAT OLD SCHOOL, MAN.
YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
- I THOUGHT I DID, MAN.
WHAT, LIKE, UH, WU-TANG CLAN?
- PSHH.
WU-TANG CLAN?
COME ON, MAN,
THOSE FOOLS JUST CAME OUT.
HOOK A BROTHER UP
WITH SOME OF THAT OLD SCHOOL.
- OKAY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU LOOKING FOR, MAN.
N.W.A.?
- N.W.A.?
COME ON, MAN, WHAT DO
I LOOK LIKE, A KID OUT THERE?
TALKING ABOUT THE N.W.A.,
FO' SHIZZLE, MY NIZZLE,
KRIS KROSS, APPLESAUCE,
WHO'S THE BOSS?,
TONY DANZA AT A LOSS.
I DON'T KNOW IT, ALL RIGHT?
I'M TALKING
ABOUT THAT OLD SCHOOL.
- OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S MY BAD,
OLD MAN, ALL RIGHT?
WE GONNA TAKE IT BACK,
ALL RIGHT?
I'M GONNA BUST OUT SOME RUN DMC
FOR YOU RIGHT NOW.
- RUN DMC?
[laughing]
COME ON, MAN, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT NONE OF THIS RUN DMC,
WOULDN'T WANT TO BE A,
ONOMATOPOEIA,
GRAB A DONKEY BY THE TOE,
GIVE HIM GONORRHEA.
I DON'T KNOW IT,
ALL RIGHT?
ALL I KNOW
IS SOME OLD SCHOOL.
AND IF YOU CAN'T GIVE IT TO ME,
YOU CAN'T GIVE IT TO ME.
- COME ON, MAN,
RUN DMC IS OLD SCHOOL.
- AH...
- WELL, CAN YOU NAME A GROUP?
- YOU THE DJ MAN.
I AIN'T TRYING TO TELL YOU
HOW TO DO YOUR JOB.
- GRANDMASTER FLASH.
- OH, MAN, GRANDMASTER FLA--
YOU SOUNDING LIKE
A KID YOURSELF,
TALKING ABOUT
GRANDMASTER FLASH TO THE--
[rapping gibberish]
DON'T STOP THE BOOGIE TO THE
BANG BANG BOOGIE TO UPCHUCK--
WHY PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT UPCHUCK?
- SUGAR HILL GANG.
- BROTHER, HOW WE END UP
IN CANDYLAND?
- YOU KNOW WHAT, MAN?
IF YOU WANT SOME OLD SCHOOL,
THEN YOU COME BACK HERE
AND FIND IT YOURSELF.
I'M GOING ON BREAK.
- ALL RIGHT, THEN, WELL,
GET MYSELF BACK HERE RIGHT HERE.
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
BACK HERE.
WHAT WE GOT?
LET'S SEE--
NOPE, NOPE, NOPE, NOPE,
NOPE, NOPE, NOPE, NOPE.
AH, THERE,
NOW WE TALKING.
[1920s jazz music]
AH, YEAH.
DADDY.
- WHAT THE [bleep]
IS HAPPENING?